okay hello everyone welcome to another
one of our design reviews heading for
awesome language version 13.1
this is another iteration of machine
learning design review
so we last time talked about feature
impact plot and i think we're down to
uh train image content detector is that
correct
yeah there's not much to see there in
the documentation because nothing is
explicitly
changed it's just that it uses a better
network underneath a more modern network
so it's smaller and it's uh
the fastest almost
a little one
the to evaluate uh it's a little slower
to no it's almost at the same time to
train i would say um
[Music]
what have we have we used this
internally yet to train anything
particularly interesting
well i have a bunch of detectors trained
for the the benchmark of course
but we could in principle do do
something more i want to retrain as soon
as we are done with the image and if i
retraining i want to use it to retrain
image cases
hey can i train it on my handwriting
to find your handwriting in an image to
identify the letters
oh
yeah
i think can i train it on something
because like i've got things that i
wrote out
you know 40 years ago where i've got the
written version i've got a typed version
which is societable
i mean if we could segment the letters i
don't know i'm just i'm just trying to
look i i think it will be a bit uphill
you you you would probably get better
results uh i think mikhail had a demo
project for handwriting uh recognition
and uh using a specialized network
probably save ups the tons of training
time okay all right okay
but i mean it would be good to use this
and put some results on the neural net
repository if we can yeah yeah then that
was the idea
we just got stuck on the this image and
definitely training that we wanted to
take out first and we're using it to
update a bunch of things in our training
pipeline internal training pipeline that
will reflect also outside
okay find clusters
so
that's the i put tentative a new
proposal um
this is very i mean by the way is this
okay that i skipped these ones i mean
this is
uh well if you are curious you can go to
the
feature value dependency plot uh i put
an example that you suggested last time
uh
about the i mean i still have to refine
that a bit but it shows uh how with the
linear um
no no no sorry no not this one the the
feature value impact plot
i'm getting confused myself
you can click on the related features
um
come on we can do better here no no the
that's the bug it's it's using transform
features uh i'm fixing that so this is
why there are not so many examples here
okay
the feasible impact processor is a
number three that you had there you were
asking if we can see the impact for a
linear detector and a non-linear and so
if you go to the first example
you'll see that
so this is a simple
linear linear model and you see
immediately that the
linear data linear model
and you see that the impact is
distributed in a linear way around the
average and it's exactly the the
difference between the
the predictor mean and the predictor
output okay
and if you look at the second one you
have a non-linear data set
and if you try to predict it with a
linear model you see that the two
features are of course uncorrelated and
they each one gives its own impact but
if you use a non-linear model like
gradient booster tree now suddenly uh
each uh
each example will split according to the
other feature because there is a
non-linear effect
and um
like each example like has an impact of
figure one which is also conditioned on
feature two in this case
boy one of the things that could be an
update to etienne's book already
yeah i think i mean
this i will i'm building some of these
uh it will grow a lot the the example
section it can show a lot of things for
all these models
that's interesting that's good
um
is this our multi-panel plot
yes
that has this gutter weird gutter thing
between the two plot
regions
uh i'm using the default one i haven't
changed anything but uh
we already found some some issues that
um i reported all to like i i'm working
with brett to to enumerate all of these
so he's giving another look at this i
can record also this this kind of thing
well i mean i think i i i thought we
were going to slightly
lighter gray frames when we had all
these i don't know it just doesn't it
looks a little weird it's not terrible
so there's no aesthetic update for
thirteen one that will be for thirteen
two we're gonna
so so it's the same as thirty now
okay all right fine
but of course this is using the the
default one so it will inherit whatever
updates
okay
uh find clusters
okay so the main difference here is that
people were asking for
um
so this is this life breaking change
that we discussed before like uh right
now if you say flying clusters data coma
n
it's basically up to n
and people are very confused by this
so now i made it so that n is actually n
and uh
up to n is supported and is your
behavior why don't you put that in the
box up here and up to n
thing i think you should
uh okay yeah it's explained it's
explained down there but i can promote
it to the top
well
oh maybe it's okay down here
so long as there's an example fairly
quickly with it
yeah i'm waiting for the pr to be
approved but the yeah this is this is
already this is ready i will put
examples here as soon as this merged
into master
okay one one slight design um
thing that we are trying to to solve
here uh maybe it would be nice to to
discuss it here uh if there are
preferences the team is a bit split on
this so we don't have the consensus is
um
what's the best result if you have only
three points and you ask for 10 clusters
um do we pad with empty clusters or we
just fail with the message that you
don't have enough points
i'm trying to try to think which one is
the neatest in terms of like you you
mean this thing of n
the main use case is that uh you don't
want to be bothered you know of checking
that each uh that you're clusterizing a
bunch of things and then you need to go
in and check again that each one has
exactly n clusters so like this this
will fix that so i'm trying to think
which is the expectation here well if
you if you have too few data points for
the number of clusters you've requested
exactly you have like three points and
you ask 10 clusters well i think you
should get a message
and then
it should just return every point in its
own cluster
okay so we do break the fact that the
length of the
of the cluster list is exactly n in this
case
i think we give a message when we break
that's what i think
okay
by break mean not returning no no i mean
i think then we return the thing with
whatever clusters we can get
what do you think roger do you have a
comment on that
i mean
how important is it to get exactly
10 because you you you can have up to 10
in which case you need to check how many
you get
yeah if it's super important sure you
can have a bunch of empty lists but it
seems no no no no no we don't want to do
that
okay
okay i think it's fine i mean if you
give a message and then you give the
wrong number it's just fine
okay
okay
which is i think is the current
implementation right now
okay
so
you know clearly we need to be looking
at these other neural net frameworks
and have you been actively looking at
those or not yes of course
we we have a design like our monthly
check-in where we can discuss strategy
uh
about that but yes that's fine
but that's i mean on nx i think it's
something that
we have good support for
and
it's it's a good exercise for us to to
finish it and i think we
until it exists
and it's it's used we want to keep it it
makes no sense to drop it i don't know i
mean
it's no no we we need to always support
onyx i think for foreseeable future
exactly and so mateo is doing good good
uh job in term of like uh being able to
import everything that exists in onyx
and on the converse like uh adding
export for our more exotic operators
like we have a very customized attention
layer like some folding operators so
all of these can can now be exported in
on nx
all right so which of these things
should we be looking at here um
um
i mean these are like
all a bunch of like we support a lot
more things for these layers um
i don't think that any other one below
require like specific attention
the more visually
impactful ones are the
the update to them
to the nether coordinate decoder that um
the class decoder and the image
encoder
that basically are like compilation of a
lot of features that were like missing
and then we we added so the class
decoder
is
you can use the fourth one in the list
um
[Music]
we we needed a much more refined
sampling strategy for tax tax generation
which now we have
i think you if you click on class you
you'll see that
the
one two three do we have a separate
documentation yes yes one of them
so if you scroll down a bit
what what is this how does it indicate
why doesn't this
source page indicate what type of a
thing it is uh it does when it's built
okay so i'm going to make a suggestion
this is for
um uh
for avery um
to feedback to the docutools people the
fact that these source pages should have
some indication of what type they are
this is pretty confusing i'm not seeing
what this is
yep i can do that
so you you see that we added if you
scroll up
to the nodes
which i'm sorry them yeah we added these
uh
temperature probability cutoff and top
probabilities which these are called
typically top k and top p sampling so
you
if you're assembling from a distribution
you only take the first uh like k
classes
by probability or the the topi the
nuclear sample is you you accumulate the
probability uh up to a certain cut off
and this gives to the race to much more
natural uh
like language generation model for
example
okay so the the performance of our
language models is improved dramatically
due to dramatically
and we can actually now reproduce the
results from gpt2 and uh i mean the
models that we have in the repo uh they
are much better match due to what's in
the literature
that's good
um um another nice one which is uh i
think was
will allows us to to get away with a lot
of custom uh encoders
is uh the image encoder has been updated
uh to support a lot more
specification for images like
custom resampling custom padding
basically this is very useful for all
the object detectors
and
[Music]
it's doing something similar to what
conform images can do or or um
image collage like stretch the image fit
the image to a specific shape
uh not just simple resizing and and this
is interesting for object action because
you don't alter the aspect ratio of the
image and and so you you can detect more
easily all the objects
wait a minute so
it has some some visuals if you click on
the net encoder and then image you can
immediately see that
see like the final four options i knew
and according to the method option you
have different uh
okay but so
i mean this is
how are we rippling through our various
existing
networks and so on to make use of all
these fancy new options well there there
was a bit of debate about this the
research system uh
now supports uh proper versioning so
what we
the the the path we are we we chose is
to
to leave the uh i mean if you call the
the network from another mathematica
or
in whatever world from language version
you're using uh it will it will use the
most up-to-date model compatible with
that
so like
we don't want to break compatibility you
know
it will still work on version 10 if it
was worse at least with 10.
but if you download it from a new
version you you will get
like richer layers which are encoders
which are decoders or a simplified
structure if it's possible
we are doing this for all the models
where it makes sense basically
okay
good all right well let's see anything
else that we need to look at in this
meeting
uh documentation wise no i mean the rest
was pretty fast the the i didn't know if
you wanted to go through the impact
plots again but uh
if you're satisfied with those names
um i think if you're satisfied with
those names i'm satisfied with your
names i
we have clear idea for the design
um
we have we have ways to specify features
and classes and so i mean it seems
pretty solid now at this point
the only thing that were they designed
were their visual design issues as well
um
i mean there are some things that came
out while i was reviewing with brett but
i reported i mean they're all like
little bugs in visualization that things
we don't like like uh placement of
labels and stuff like that but they're
not specific to these functions
we like stress testing some of them a
bit more
okay
um sounds good all right anything else
to look at here
i guess not if you don't know there's
nothing very
documentation oriented there there's a
lot of under the hood updates on loss
functions and
what's happening
the progress monitoring stuff that is
that yeah i haven't heard much in this
version about progress monitoring
a lot of functions
it was it was under the hood project so
like it's been i don't know i updated
manually ping time uh net train and the
classified predictor using the new
system so now if you go to the
classified page on your train you see
what's using the new
uh is using the the new progress grid
and
i think yeah avery has a big notebook
when he's tracking all the updates but
uh it has been propagated to
quite a few functions now at this point
good well i mean but what's the roadmap
for propagating it
to yet more
well the difficult one i'm helping and
uh i think every is pestering everything
with uh uh are you here every
yeah i'm here okay uh
yeah i mean we do keep an up-to-date
list and you are like once in a while
you are pinging the things that are are
not transitioned yet yeah but more or
less
i was too fast uh just use time goal and
a big number
yeah or a thousand or something like
that
that looks very similar to the way it
looked before doesn't it
well the design of the new one wasn't
too far apart from the old one
it doesn't have buttons anymore and uh i
mean this this one uh i don't know why
probably marco
doesn't have the um
i see display those are the big the the
big thing yeah because it's just one
model here
but the first one is showing it so the
thing is it is aligned i mean if you
look at them side by side now they're
all aligned basically they're not using
anything custom anymore
that was the main the main point and
they use the common infrastructure so if
we ever decide to update it they will
all be updated at the same time
okay
well this is good then we we have a
discussion uh
we had the discussion about monitoring
other updates but i think that's a
separate thing is like how we bring it
to top level but
it's kind of on a separate track then
updating the internal process monitoring
yes but we want that i mean we want
we talked about another meeting and
being able to monitor map and things
like this exactly exactly we are
tracking that in during the lccc
meetings okay
listen let's declare victory we we we
are early here it's great yes i've got
other things that i need to take care of
before me
so good work all right roger said we're
not missing anything no no
excellent thank you for being early okay
see you guys